Hi, I'm Brianna from free code camp and today we're going to talk about the basics of computer hardware
computers are made up of four basic parts the
Input/output CPU and memory the input is what you're putting into the computer. Think about mouse keyboard
Microphone. Anyway, you're giving data into the computer the output is what you're watching on your monitor or listening to on your speakers
These can both be any format like text numbers
Videos images what have you it doesn't matter the CPU stands for central processing unit
And that's what we all think of when we think of a computer
It's what does the functions it's what runs a software it manipulates the data
The memory is where we store data and information now the CPU has exclusive access to this memory
You can get to the memory from the input or from the output without the use of the CPU
so just review we've got four basic parts of a computer the
input/output CPU and memory
In addition to those four basic parts, we have three more things we're going to discuss today the motherboard
expansion cards and power supply
The motherboard is what connects everything while the data is flying around over here trying to figure out where to go
The motherboard helps route it so it goes to the right place
Expansion cards are sound cards video cards that kind of thing that can really up your experience as a user
Power supply is as it sounds what gets power to the computer
It's usually a part of the computer that has that fan on it to keep it from overheating
so let's do a quick review in addition to the four basic parts of
Input/output central processing unit and memory, we usually have a motherboard expansion cards and a power supply
We're going to talk about the different types of computers
the biggest type of computer we're going to talk about is a supercomputer, which maybe you've heard of a
Supercomputer uses a whole bunch of CPUs and uses something called
Parallel processing all of those CPUs work on the same problem at the same time
The next type we're going to talk about is a server a server
holds and accesses a bunch of data or programs
Our website free code camp is hosted on a server which stores all that information
Next let's talk about a workstation computer now a workstation computer just looking at it might look similar to a personal computer
But it has a bunch more power and is way more expensive Toy Story was built on
workstation computers
Now personal computers by far the most common type of computers
Maybe you've heard I'm a Mac. I'm a PC something like they're different but really this map is still just a PC
It's a it's a personal computer. It's still a book the Mac and a PC
The last type of computer we're going to talk about is a microcontroller
microcontroller that's the type of tiny computer you might have in your car that has a really
Specialized task and is really good that one small thing but it's not like you could use it like a regular personal computer
So just to review
5,000 computers
supercomputer server workstation PC and microcontroller
We're going to be talking a little bit more about the motherboard now the motherboard we mentioned briefly
We're going to go into a little bit more detail today
So what makes a motherboard is the connection between the CPU?
And the memory if there's no connection between the central processing unit and the memory
We can't call it a motherboard but most motherboards do a lot more than that primarily
they have expansion slots and
Ports now expansion slots are where you put anything that can increase the performance of the computer
without putting more load on the CPU
For example a graphics or a sound card would up your user experience by giving you a better video or better sound quality
but it wouldn't slow down anything that the CPU had to do a
Network interface card could also go in an expansion slot. This would help your computer connect with the networks around it
We'll talk about networks a little bit more in videos coming up now a PC card
Which has really been turned mostly over to Express cards are found primarily in
Laptops because of the size Express card is better. It's just much smaller
In addition to expansion slots motherboards have ports now on your computer
I'm sure you know, there's a place where you can plug in a USB cord
firewire SD card
Ethernet even an audio plug in so you can listen through headphones now
These are all considered ports a place on the motherboard where you can connect the CPU
To some outside source, either to get or give information
So just a quick review of the motherboard at its very minimum connect the CPU and the memory
But it also has expansion slots and ports
And we're going to talk about the basics of software
We've already covered hardware which are parts of the computer that you can actually see and feel with your hands
Software are the programs that run on the hardware. You can't pick up a piece of software
you can pick up a piece of hardware with the software downloaded onto it but
Software is the code that is written and imprinted on to hardware
The two main types of software that we're going to talk about are the operating system like Windows
Mac or Linux. Those are the main three you're not really gonna get any more than that or
applications now everything that you think of a software probably falls into these two
spaces especially the applications
Applications cover everything from your web browser to games to things like Photoshop or your mail how you edit documents
every type of system application that is not an operating system is
Just a regular software application
the big takeaway from this video is that
Hardware is what you can actually hold on to from a computer, but software
Consists of all the programs that you can run on that hardware
Now binary code is a really really basic simple computer language where there's just once and
There zeros, there's by two things ones and zeros ones meaning on zeros meaning off
So think of like a light switch which in some cases in super old computer
There was an actual switch which was either on or off
one thing on 0 being off so
Bunch of ones and zeros, they can mean pretty much anything. But really they're mostly meant to be numbers and letters
we're gonna go in a little bit on how you actually decode binary or translate a number to binary code but
Really as you guessed you can usually just google binary translator and have that figured out the most important part of this
Do you understand the concept that even?
Basic things like zeros and ones can translate it
But something really really complex and is the basis for all of the computer languages and programs that exist today
We're gonna start by labeling starting backwards
How many numbers there are this will be 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 pretty straightforward
so far
The next step that we're going to do is take two to the power of whatever places so here
It'll be 2 to the 0 2 to the 1 - 2 - 2 to the 3 you get the picture
All right. Now that we got the 2 to the given power figured out
All you gotta do is fill in some links and we'll have our solution 2 to the 0 is you got it
1 2 to the 1 is
2 2 to the 2 is
4 we've got 8 16 32 64 and that just keeps going on on
Next what we're gonna do is see. Okay, which one of these numbers do we keep?
alright, so the next step figure out which numbers do we keep do we just add up all the things together and if these were
All ones then. Yes, we would but some of them are zeros
The zero is the same thing as like an off switch one being on zero being off
So we can go ahead and cross all of these out right here because they're they're not gonna really matter
We want to keep this one this one here and here because they have the corresponding ones
Which means yes, it's on we want to keep that number
Basically from here on out. We're just gonna add these four numbers together getting us we've got 70 Tuesday for 75, so
this number in binary means
We're gonna be talking about data size the smallest size of data
You can possibly have is called a bit now. That is I wrote a one here. That's an example of a bit
It can really either only be a one or a zero
It really goes back to that binary that we were talking about one me non
Zero meaning off it can either be a one or zero that's a bit bigger than that
We've got a nibble which is four bits. It's not very commonly used but it's adorable. I'm bigger than that
We've got a bite now. This is common referring to something in a byte
It is an eight bit put together
now a lot of
binary things are expressed with eight bits like letters and symbols and one most numbers really can be expressed that way until you get two
really big ones so our most basic data sizes
You got a bit and a byte but as you can guess it gets much bigger than that
All right
So after we get past the regular small bit and the first little byte which is eight bits
We get bigger really fast. The next step up is a kilobyte which is
1,024 bytes which times eight is a whole lot more bits after the kilobyte. We've got megabyte which is
1,024 to power of two which is the same thing as
1,048,576 bytes
so
Since we're growing exponentially that is a big big increase after megabyte
We've got gigabyte also known as GB which is 1,024 to the power of 3, then TB terabyte
1,024 to the power 4 and PD not peanut butter. It is henna byte
1024 to the power of 5 just to give you an idea of how big this number is if you can't see it
I almost ran out of room writing this on my whiteboard
These are some pretty big numbers. We're dealing with here
You probably recognize megabyte gigabyte terabyte
From regular storage that you've dealt with before on your iPad your iPod your computer or anything like that
Alright just a quick review bit tiny little either 1 or 0 byte 8 bits
kilobyte
1,024 bytes
after that, everything is an exponent off of
1024 going from kilobyte to megabyte to gigabyte terabyte all the way up to the petabytes
We're gonna be talking about data speed
Davis, speed unlike data size is usually measured in bits per second
Whereas size is measured in bytes
Big difference being bytes is eight times bigger than bits at the very smallest level once we start talking
Exponentially that makes a really big difference
How we talk about speed kind of depends on what we're talking about when we talk about the speed of like an audio
Download we talked about kilobits per second
Kilobits not kilobytes totally different number today
We're talking about an internet speed like the speed that your internet service provider gives you they usually measure that in megabits per second
So 1 million bits per second. The network speed is something we talked about in gigabits per second
So a billion bits per second biggest distinction here bits versus bytes
Data speed is generally measured in bits
Data size is measured in bytes
Another thing we want to discuss just because they have an internet speed that says you get a certain amount of download
That doesn't mean you're gonna be able to download that many bytes per minute per second. That's just not gonna happen
They're talking about bits. It's gonna take you a little bit longer to do that since your data size is dealing with bytes
We're going to be talking about the very most basic level the computers can understand other languages like JavaScript
The most basic thing like we've already talked about is a bit up or down 1 or 0 on top of that
We've got the biked 8 bit but together all
Letters numbers and symbols can be broken down into bytes that the computer can understand at the most basic level
So that means all of the letters and symbols that you're using in your JavaScript can be translated into byte now
There are a lot of languages that the computer uses at the most basic levels to run just the operating system
But what I want you to get away from this lesson, is that everything in your computer boils down to binary bytes?
We're going to be talking about data networks
You've heard of networks before maybe a wider network a road network even a television network or a cell phone network
Today we're talking about data networks, which are the networks that computers use those three types
we're going to cover in this video are the local area network the wide area network and the Virtual Private Network a
Local area network is just a small group of computers that are connected together
The most important thing about a local area network is that those computers are close together?
so your Wi-Fi at Starbucks or at a school that is
local area network that you can only connect to if you're actually close to that a
Wide area network is two local area networks that have been connected over a long distance
So maybe a school in Colorado wants to connect with the school in Missouri. They could use a wide area network
You might think that those are connected over the internet and in the case of a virtual private network
Which accomplishes basically the same thing as a wide area network it is
VPNs use the Internet to connect there to local area networks
However, a wide area network will usually rent a cable from an Internet company and connect that way
So just to review a local area network is a group of computers connected
Close to each other a wide area network in a virtual private network are two
Local area networks or more than have been connected over long distances the wide area network
Accomplishes this by renting a line from an Internet company and a virtual private network. Does it over the Internet?
We're going to be talking about the internet part 1 how the internet works to know how the internet works
We're going to talk first about IP addresses. You might be familiar with the fact that each of your devices has its own IP address
Just like a house or apartment has its own actual address the internet can't deliver data to a device unless it has an IP address
Not only does your device have an IP address
But so does the modem and the router and every step along the way in the internet, which we'll get to later
IP addresses are determined based on location
starting in five big international
Regions that's on this side as you get down the line each of these numbers brings you to a more specific location
Now this number isn't specific enough that you could call 911 your IP address and they could find your house
But it is specific enough where if you google find the best Ice Cream Sandwich near me
Google can help you out there and actually give you something close to your location
what I want you to take away from this video is that every device that connects to the Internet has an IP address and
That it needs that IP address the information knows where to go
Let's talk a little bit more about how the internet works
We've already established that every device and every other thing along the way in the Internet has its own IP address
Now these IP addresses are assigned based on location
using these IP addresses
Your device can talk to your modem
Which you probably have in your home then to a router which is set up by your web service
The router would go to the domain name server
This is still just sending a request
Now that domain name server would send back the information that was asked for and it would go right back to your device
Now you might think this is pretty fallible
If one of these steps goes out the whole process is done
but
Really?
There's so many more connections with so many routers and so many servers is if one huge chunk of the internet goes out
That still won't really affect the functionality of anything else. There are just intimate connections. It's amazing
Now what I want you to take away from this video is that your device since it has its own IP address?
can send out a request for information that
Information is sent back to your device
The way it gets to your device is because of the IP
Address and the way it gets there is through all the lines of the modems and routers and servers that make up the Internet
We are going to talk about something called a CDN and a content delivery network
Now the concept of a CDN, isn't that hard to wrap your head around?
What the CDN does is make a faster and smoother user experience by delivering content to the user faster
It doesn't have to go through all the channels of the internet
It creates a faster and more direct route from the site to the user
When I first was learning about CD ends
I got really confused because I thought well doesn't everybody benefit from that who's paying for the service?
is that the user they'll pay for a CDN to make their internet faster or is that the website that pays a
CDN to deliver their content and it's the latter a
CDN is hired by a website or in some cases developed by a website. It's it's own CDN
Then that CB n pays an internet service provider to help determine the fastest routes
now what you need to know about CBN's in the big picture is
They are hired by sites or created by sites to make the user experience
faster an
Example of a CDN that you should know about as a developer is how Google hosts languages like jQuery
If you link to jQuery from Google's library instead of uploading it yourself to your site that's going to be way faster for your user
Additionally if another site has used that same
CDN for jQuery, it might be stored in that users browser. So it doesn't even have to load again all
As a user you need to know that CD ends are everywhere
You probably use CD ends all the time without really even needing to be aware as a developer
It's important for things like the languages that are hosted on Google libraries
you can use those in your sites and create a much faster user experience with less work on your end than before as a
Big company, you might need to see the end to do something specifically for you
You might want your site to be on the fast track to your users and you might need a CDN to do that
All I want you to take away from this video is that CD ends are content delivery networks
They are all over the place and they make a faster user experience
We're gonna talk about analog versus digital on a really basic level most specifically we're going to talk about how computers
interpret an analog sound and turned it into a digital file an
Analogue sound wave would look something like this
This would be like a perfect sine wave which would not really ever be heard of nature
But that's beside the point this analog sound wave the computer takes that and measures at all these different points
measures those and turns those into numbers based on this point right here so we could go up and say oh this is
Point two seven says point one six and this is negative one point two
Later, the computer could take those numbers and reinterpret them and turn them into actual sound again
we're also going to discuss a little bit of data compression how
Computers compress data that is the sound file and image file or a video file now
The benefit of compression is that it's a smaller file
So it's easier to store it takes up less space and it's easier to send to somebody else
One of the ways this is done in sound is it would take it less often?
The sampling would be every two or every three another way is that it would just go up to here and say, okay
This is point two seven. Well, we're just gonna measure everything from here
So it's negative three negative two negative one from there. If everything was around that same area in
images this is done by taking the little tiniest possible pixels and just
Measuring it in groups of sixteen and finding kind of the average color of that
The most important thing to take away from this video is you're gonna want to use digital files
They're gonna have a better quality
And when you're looking at compression you really need to look at how far you're willing to go to ensure that the user still has
the best experience
We are gonna talk a little bit more about routers and how they relate to networking
Routers are the things that connect different small area networks. I want to give kind of a metaphor for this
So I'm a teacher I work at a school
Let's say I have a package that I need to get to somebody that works in the district offices
I don't know where her office is exactly, but I know her name I go to my secretary
That would be this is me. This is my secretary I go to my secretary
I say hey, I need to get this to so-and-so at the district office. Can you please help me out here?
She'll say oh sure. I don't know exactly where her office is here, but I know how to get there
I know the next step
So even though I didn't know the next step she does so she goes on and sends it on to the secretary of the district
Office now that district office secretary has no idea who I am or where I am
But she knows the end location what I'm trying to get across here is each router
Only has to know its own little network only the stops right next to it
It doesn't have to know the whole internet just has to know its own connections and it can take information and say all right
I don't know exactly where that's going. But I'll pass it on to the right direction
And that's really all it takes
Routers can be different sizes different capacities
But what they do is just know their own neighborhood take the information and pass it on in the right direction
another really powerful thing that we're going to get into a little bit later is
They don't have to have the full package of information
Either if this computer is trying to send information all the way up here
It might get split up and go to two different routers and that's ok
The computers are still going to know how to put that information back together correctly
Now the little pieces of information that are sent are called packets
Packets are actually little pieces of binary code, which I'm going to draw up here for you
Alright, so this is an example of what a packet might look like
It's just this line that goes up and then down and up and down and is either up or it's down
That is an electrical current. So a computer gets back and can translate that into ones and zeros
Which we all know is a binary code the way it does that is it drivelines a certain distance apart
Basically and if it's up is the one if it's it's a zero as we discussed in previous videos
This one and zero business can really mean a whole lot more fact. It means
Everything everything can be translated into ones and zeros. So this is really powerful
um, these little packets are sent across through these routers and
Sometimes if there's a file that's too large for one packet
It can be broken up into frames or smaller little packets. These packets don't have to go the same route
They go whichever box available whichever stacks just and since they have the end IP address encoded into them
All the routers know where to send them when they get to the end destination that computer knows how to put it all together